well welcome to this video yeah playing
a five minute game on the SSC against
drain you sooner Burke handsome yeah
let's see with g3 gonna bring the double
fianchetto yard that's a solid opening
with a drop of poison yeah he's playing
yeah then we have a quadruple fianchetto
now which is a gap very solid reply to
that not very exciting but okay what can
you do yeah and retakes no it's not
taking I would have taken with the Queen
leading to interesting play aha so just
esox gal might see three looks very
normal we have my guest book
yeah that's an interesting said lava I
don't I don't really know how this is
played you might go with d5 a union
leading to a very active active type of
position huh yeah d5 you can just take
twice and maybe support the center this
does not look like a very critical move
but I'm not sure how I'm and how I
should play him trying with a simple
approach maybe just Queenie to look do
you want something like that he's got
hanging pawns and it's not that that
usual to have the bishop on g7 for the
hanging plants especially if you
consider that there's a night on a 6
which makes a rather rather weird
impression it can be reroute adore
course but I'm not so sure that he can
manage this easily um maybe I can take
and soon here while we're really huh
hmm that's surprising not sure why h4s
never move really I wonder mod stuff
like night a4 or something but then you
might have 94 but then 92 okay let's do
that try to put some pressure on the c5
pond maybe I can take Bishop a three
moves like that it also know it just
takes that's interesting getting to an
IQ p position hmm ok how do how do i
take i can also take oops sorry with the
bishop which controls c5 reliably now
queen bee to may be increasing the
pressure there bit on the long diagonal
Knight to c6 yeah but I can just just
retreat then I mean I wonder how to
place pieces maybe I should cavity three
yeah I very much down on the clock I'm
certainly ok here position wise but um
yeah that time time is a problem b5 I
have covered oh come on really you're
playing that quickly and also playing
good moves is this fair Knight takes
Knight XA has got Queenie for at the end
huh yeah probably i can i cannot take
with the night
Black is just just in good shape and
then 11 minute 35 it's very active yes I
made some imprecisely the starting of
this like age 5 and so on widest in
white is a very good position but
probably members were just not
harmonious enough here is very much
possible that he has some tactic because
the other the bishop on g7 Queen not be
too and everything it looks very shaky
it looks very shaky the I am it's very
much possible that to something like
this is going to work okay but Bishop g2
Bishop g2 yeah come on this is okay
right it cannot sacrifice the Queen iya
shouldn't shouldn't work can take you
for I can
I mean I cannot a musty lack resign and
now I'm a piece upright and he resigned
what do we add game you must take with
the Queen huh I'm still a bit stunned by
all this what happened to him I mean
around here I absolutely don't believe
that this is any good for black I mean
why should should should have some
advantage it's not clear how much it is
but age 5 does not belong into this and
the night on a 6 is also not good so it
is at best equal for black well sort
what stockfish is giving me zero point
six I don't know but definitely I should
be ok but here I'm not sure I maybe did
something wrong Queen B 2 looks quite
quite normal but hmm ok so here the
computer suggests to just take on c8 and
play 95 now maybe that's better it's
possible yeah that this isn't such a
great idea but yeah while the computer
is still on equal it's not also hear
hear I ahead gives black an edge so
probably yeah Bishop everyone yeah I
need to take him and then probably
Bishop takes and go from there 95 or
something yeah this should be ok I mean
why should I be worse here I don't
really see it so this must be ok i'm
clint here I suffer from slightly
uncoordinated position so maybe 93 just
controlling the center better and get
this night back in to play Earth's maybe
maybe maybe right this is a very strong
move yeah should be too and here instead
of taking
I'm not saying that this is bad but the
computer is is quite positive that this
is very strong and I very much believe
that yeah i mean he's won d 4 ton of
times and I'm really uncoordinated with
this bad night and f3 is lose and the
long diagonal and this is looks better
and he threatening to take that's very
good for black very tough to even get
some sort of position probably I will
lose upon somewhere at least yeah but
this is not I mean even here if he takes
on d4 I wasn't it would happen so quick
that I didn't but I thought that this
probably should be good for me because
he has this this enormous traffic jam
here on the on the G file yeah my mom
I'm here I'm on a mononym this and the
bishop yeah this is winning four wide so
he was losing here anyway after Bishop
g2 weird yeah sometimes it gets it hurts
you if you play instant moves all the
time even if you thought about it
beforehand and here i'm just-just this
piece up for 4 zip yeah nothing at all
strange very strange yeah but this is
simply good for black so my my maneuvers
here with Queen B 2 and so on one
successful I need to rethink this
probably maybe I can also take and go
from there somehow it's not it's not so
harmonious but that is this self
certainly okay yeah but what you played
with d4 in the game was very strong okay
thanks for watching